[Music]
live from the Kodak Theatre at Hollywood
and Highland in Los Angeles California
the Academy of Motion Picture Arts and
Sciences invites you to the 78th annual
Academy Awards
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen please welcome your
host for the 78th annual Academy Awards
mr. Billy Crystal oh I can't do it right
now I'm busy I'm busy too
ladies and gentlemen your host mr. Steve
Martin not this year this year I'm gonna
spend more time with the kids you know
so they don't grow up weird
[Music]
please welcome your host Miss Whoopi go
hell now ladies and gentlemen mr. David
Letterman sorry I would really love to
but I can't I need to spend more time
with Steve Martin's kids you know so
they don't grow up weird
[Music]
please welcome mr. Mel Gibson Rankine
cata to - no cash to play the issue beta
in ook eek like a cha then a quinoa K
Matheny
[Applause]
[Applause]
thank you for selecting mr. Moviefone to
host the Academy Awards mr. pokey phone
is not interested I just had the
weirdest dream
they were about to ask me to host the
Oscars really yeah what actually makes
you think you're awake now
oh because of the mmm-hmm Flynn was
going out too good in my dream
[Music]
so soon dream No
[Music]
start to show
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen your host for the
78th annual Academy Awards please
welcome John Stewart
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you thank you all very much I'm so
excited to be here good evening
everybody ladies gentlemen felicity I'm
Jon Stewart and welcome to the 78th
annual Academy Awards an exciting night
an exciting night
tonight is the night we celebrate
excellence in film with me
the fourth male lead from death to
smoochy rent it and right now around the
world we are being watched by hundreds
of millions of people
nearly half of whom are in the process
of being adopted by Angelina Jolie I'm
wait-listed it's good stuff
it isn't crap I have to say it's a
little shocking to see all these big
names here these huge stars the Oscars
is really I guess the one night of the
year where you could see all your
favorite stars without having to donate
any money to the Democratic Party and
it's exciting for the stars as well this
is the first time many of you have ever
voted for a winner
oh it's good you're enjoy enjoy your
votes the theme of the award show
tonight is a return to glamour and thank
goodness because for too long
Hollywood has done without definitely
this is an improvement over last year's
theme night of a thousand sweat pants
let's face facts it hasn't been the best
year for Hollywood the box office was a
little bit down and piracy continues to
be a problem so let me just say if
there's anyone out there involved in
illegal movie piracy don't do it take a
good look at these people these are the
people you're stealing from look at them
face what you've done there are women
here who could barely afford enough gown
to cover their breasts
there are a lot of really big stars here
tonight it's really exciting we've got
the man mr. George Clooney triple
nominate no stop it stop it it's you
it's a it's a terrific night to the
nominations for a good night and good
luck which is not just Edward our Murrow
sign-off it's also how mr. Clooney ends
all his dates now
a kid because I envy the cast of Capote
is also with us a tremendous film
groundbreaking I applaud you the pody
was a groundbreaking film that broke
taboos that showed America not all gay
people are virile Cowboys some are
actually a feat New York intellectuals
it's true
Capote of course addressed very similar
themes to good night and good luck
both films are about determined
journalists defying obstacles in a
relentless pursuit of the truth needless
to say both are period pieces
there's also Steven Spielberg is here
sir a pleasure we've never met a Best
Director nomination for Munich a
tremendous film and I congratulate you
sir from the man who also gave us
Schindler's List Schindler's List and
Munich I think I speak for all Jews when
I say I can't wait to see what happens
to us next
[Applause]
trilogy
yeah I do have some sad news to report
Bjork couldn't be here tonight she was
trying on her Oscar dress and Dick
Cheney shot her
tragedy really charlize theron is here
nominated for North Country a tremendous
performance I congratulate you as well
if you haven't seen the film it's it's
it's really wonderful she plays a woman
who was constantly judged on her looks
and paid less than her male co-workers
it must be wonderful to be done with
that and back here in Hollywood
I think first-time nominee Matt Dillon
is joining us a wonderful career I've
enjoyed his work for many many years I
wanted to beat him for many many years
he was in crash his co-star Sandra
Bullock right next to him also in crash
Terrence Howard is here Don Cheadle
Brendan Fraser Ryan Philippe also from
crash you know what actually you know it
would be easier raise your hand if you
were not in crash but all the films this
year that have been nominated are
excellent films they deal with racism
corruption terrorism and censorship it's
why we go to the movies to escape
I'll tell you the movies that do very
well the remakes King Kong and made that
a couple of times this time smash hit
War of the Worlds remake tremendous walk
the line is Rey with white people
remakes see Jamie I know but I have to
say I'm from New York and I've been out
here a week and I have had a great time
I really mean that and a lot of people
say that this town is too liberal out of
touch with mainstream America an
atheistic pleasure-dome a modern-day
beachfront Sodom and Gomorrha immoral
black hole where innocence is
obliterated in an endless orgy of sexual
gratification and greed I don't really
have a joke here I am I just thought you
should know a lot of people are saying
that
well I've been to the parties there you
go now you're talking a lot of times at
the Oscars people aren't quite sure how
the presenters come out how the order is
determined so tonight we're going to try
something a little bit different we're
going to be introducing the presenters
in order of how talented they are know